All right. Well, moving on.
Apparently, the early 2,000's count as ancient history.
Mashable, this gets me extra-valley girl.
Mashable reports that young people are falling back in love
with the old relic called the flip phone.
(people gasping)
Vinyl sales are up.
Yes.
Next thing you know,
we're gonna be hawking eight tracks.
(people laughing)
The latest in something called Vintage Tech Nostalgia,
where young people dig up your old favorites
and they act like they're brand new.
So they're buying old Motorola Razors,
old Samsung flip phones-
The razor.
and hooking them up and using them.
Yeah. Mm-hmm.
Rossy, did you ever have...
I had this exact pink Razor.
Do you guys remember this one?
I feel like this is my old one.
I never had one of these either.
What did you have?
Well, the truth of the matter is,
is I avoided cell phones for many years.
Really? Why?
I wasn't ready for them
and I had a Blackberry.
Oh.
And I liked the typing.
I liked the keypad.
This was like,
I wanna say hello and have to press 59 buttons?
Yes.
No.
How about just type.
I'm a typer, I'm a writer,
so I love the Blackberry.
This was the most miserable thing to text on
but the thing I loved about a flip phone was this moment,
right, when you were like,
"Well, Tiffany, I never liked you,"
and then slap it down.
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
Do you think, if they started remaking these,
would you ever consider it?
Well, the thing that's coming out of it that's a benefit
is that people aren't constantly on the internet.
Oh, yeah.
And this is a lo-fi way
to cut down on your screen time.
Try to get a Uber on this and then call me, all right.
Or don't call me because...
All right.
Thank you.
Next, it's time for us to review whatever you want us to
in Drew's Reviews.
(organ jingling)
(audience applauding)
Is it that? Oh my God.
I forgot about this.
I feel like I have steak in my teeth.
I know, I kind of keep...
I can't stop thinking about the steak though.
I know.
(people mumbling)
Okay.
Okay. Today it's an invention called the Headache Hat,
submitted by Barbara Conleigh.
(audience laughing)
Okay, wait. I just...
I just wanna say, what's in here is frozen tubes of...
I don't know.
I don't know but it's frozen and it's cold and I am lit up.
Let me tell you that.
(audience laughing)
Whoa.
Well...
That'll wake you up.
It is literally giving me brain freeze right now.
It's like...
Well, apparently...
Okay, so you store this in the freezer
and it's got a cooling gel and a snug fit
that's supposed to give you some headache relief.
Does this feel good to you right now?
It hurts so bad.
So bad.
(audience laughing)
Because I don't have a headache right now, it's...
Yeah, but I'm gonna save it for the next time I do.
Rossy, do you wanna rate it with stars?
How many?
I can't even think right now.
(audience laughing)
But yeah, I think...
Well, I can see how this would help
if you were
(audience laughing)
in severe pain
and needed to numb your head so you can't feel anything.
If this helps, it's a five star out of five for me.
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, right?
I will say that,
whenever I get really stressed out in life,
I get really bad, crippling migraines.
At one point I was sleeping with a night guard
and a neck guard.
I mean, it was so sexy.
Huh.
By the way.
I was like, "You wanna get it on?"
(audience laughing)
I'm gonna throw this on with my mouth guard
(audience cheering)
and my neck guard-
Oh my God.
and call it a day.
(upbeat music)